this is bigger than Ukraine this is a war about
freedom and it's one we have to win a win for
Ukraine is a win for all of us because tyrants
tell us exactly what they're going to do what
we heard China said they were going to take
Hong Kong they did it Russia said they were
going to invade Ukraine we watched that happen
China says Taiwan's next we better believe them
Russia said Poland and the Baltics are next
if that happens we're looking at a World War
this is about preventing war and so the way you
prevent wars not that we give cash to Ukraine not
that we put troops on the ground but that we
get with our allies and we make sure that we
give them the equipment and the ammunition to win
because when Ukraine wins that sends a message to
China with Taiwan it sends a message to Iran
that wants to build a bomb sends a message to
North Korea testing ballistic missiles and
it sends a message to Russia that it's over